there's a table of 19 and it's over 15
and a 14 pretty much coming at the same
time and it's not very good when you've
got like 48 people all at once because
it's shot in the kitchen Nick and
Richard have to learn a cardinal rule
put the customers first make them feel
really special and build a sense of
loyalty I know he's been to come out for
a family meal after wait long as this
there's not a question of fast foods
question now we've been an hour and a
half with the other starter that's it
not alive explanation of them we've been
really busy we've kept you for example
Colleen still yeah we are we learn and
we don't come back again that's how did
she came home to your table I'm not done
this many times Kim's trying her best
but Charma the customers just won't work
they want to eat release you know it's
fresh
remember unhappy customers destroy
reputations right how the [ __ ] can you
cook with nearly 50 people at one time
yeah
the food was very good yeah the rest of
it you structure the organization
I'm sorry maximal wasting stuff the pot
I mean the girl know there's you know
she's the only one on a road the guys in
the black shirts know I think that were
the managers they were sitting down
talking to their mates in the
conservatory there and there any left
two people serving everybody else on
here
unlike so goodbye mr. Wayne aspire boom
let's hope Richard and Nic learn their
lesson the dining room is empty now but
it's been full for the first time in a
long time and the vast majority of
customers went away happy